Solo vemos una parte muy pequeña de la realidad
que describen las leyes de la física cuántica,
pero, hay muchos mundos, otros mundos,
partes de la realidad que se describen
con teorías muy vastas y diferentes
que son diferentes de las nuestras y no las podemos imaginar,
que son exóticas e inconcebibles.
Steven Weinberg, el padre
del modelo estándar de la física de partículas,
ha coqueteado con esta idea,
que todas las realidades posibles realmente existen.
También, un físico joven, Max Tegmark,
cree que todas las estructuras matemáticas existen,
y la existencia matemática, es la misma cosa
que la existencia física,
así que tenemos un multiverso muy vasto
que engloba todas las posibilidades lógicas
Ahora, en la práctica de esta forma metafísica,
estos físicos y filósofos están
remontándose a una idea muy vieja
que se remonta a Platón.
Es el principio de la plenitud y la fecundidad
o la gran cadena de existir,
que la realidad es lo más completa posible.
Está tan lejos de la nada
como es posible.
Ahora tenemos estos dos extremos.
Por un lado tenemos la nada misma,
y tenemos esta visión de la realidad
que engloba todos los mundos concebibles
en el otro extremo: la realidad completa y posible
la nada, la realidad posible más simple.
Ahora, ¿qué hay entre estos extremos?
Hay todo tipo de realidades intermedias
que incluyen algunas cosas y excluyen otras.
Alguna de estas realidades intermedias
es la realidad matemática más elegante.
deja afuera las partes poco elegantes,
las asimetrías feas y así sucesivamente.
Hay algunos físicos que dirán
que uno está viviendo en la realidad más elegante.
Creo que Brian Greene está en la audiencia,
él ha escrito un libro llamado "El universo elegante".
Proclama que el universo que vivimos matemáticamente
es muy elegante.
No le crean. (Risas)
Es una esperanza piadosa, desearía que fuera cierto,
pero creo que el otro día me admitió
que realmente es un universo feo.
Está construido de forma estúpida,
tiene demasiadas constantes arbitrarias
y relaciones de masas
y familias de partículas elementales superfluas.
¿Qué demonios es la energía oscura?
Es una gomera de chicle.
No es un universo elegante. (Risas)
Y luego está el mejor de los mundos posibles
en un sentido ético.
Deberían ponerse solemnes ahora,
porque es un mundo donde las personas sensibles
no sufren innecesariamente,
donde no hay cosas como
niños con cáncer, o el Holocausto.
Esta es una concepción ética.
Entre la nada
y la mayor realidad posible,
hay realidades especiales.
La nada es especial. Es simple.
Luego está la realidad elegante.
Eso es especial.
La mayor realidad, es especial.
¿Qué estamos dejando fuera?
Hay algunas realidades de mala muerte,
realidades genéricas
que no son especiales de ninguna forma.
Son algo aleatorias.
Están infinitamente retiradas de la nada,
caen en una plenitud corta, pero completa.
Son una mezcla de caos y orden,
de elegancia matemática y fealdad.
Describiré estas realidades
como un lío infinito, mediocre e incompleto,
una realidad genérica, una mezcla de basura cósmica.
En estas realidades,
¿Hay alguna deidad en alguna de ellas?
Quizás, pero esta deidad no es perfecta
como una deidad judeo-cristiana.
No es extremadamente buena, ni todopoderosa.
En cambio, puede que sea 100 % malévola
pero solo 80 % efectiva.
Lo que más o menos describe el mundo que nos rodea, creo. (Risas)
Así que, me gustaría proponer que la resolución
al misterio de la existencia
es que la realidad en la que existimos
es una de esas realidades genéricas.
La realidad tiene que resultar de alguna manera.
Puede resultar ser nada
o todo, o un punto medio.
Así que si tiene alguna característica especial,
como ser realmente elegante o completa
o muy simple, como la nada,
eso requeriría una explicación.
Pero si es una de estas realidades genéricas,
no hay ninguna explicación para ello.
De hecho, diré que
esa es la realidad en la que vivimos.
Eso es lo que la ciencia nos está diciendo.
Al principio de esta semana,
recibimos la excitante noticia de que
la teoría de la inflación, que predice
una realidad, infinita, desordenada, arbitraria y vana,
como la espuma de un champagne
que brota de una botella incesantemente,
un universo vasto, mayormente un desierto
con pequeños lugares de encanto, orden y paz,
fue confirmada,
el escenario inflacionario, según las observaciones
de telescopios en la Antártida
avistaron las firmas de las ondas gravitacionales
producidas desde justo antes del Big Bang.
Estoy seguro que todos saben sobre este tema.
Así que de todos modos, creo que hay cierta evidencia
de que esta realidad en la que estamos atascados.
Ahora, ¿por qué debería importarles?
Bueno... (Risas)
la pregunta, "¿Por qué existe el mundo?"
es la pregunta cósmica,
en consonancia con una pregunta más íntima:
¿Por qué existo yo? ¿Por qué existen Uds.?
Saben, nuestra existencia parece ser poco probable,
porque hay una enorme cantidad de humanos genéticamente posibles,
si se puede calcular mirando
el número de genes y alelos, así sucesivamente,
y un cálculo ligero dirá
que hay unos 10 a la 10 000
humanos genéticamente posibles.
Eso es entre un gúgol y un gúgolplex
La cantidad de humanos que existió
es 100 000 millones, quizás 50 000 millones,
una fracción infinitesimal,
todos ganamos la sorprendente lotería cósmica.
Estamos aquí. Está bien.
¿En qué tipo de realidad queremos vivir?
¿Queremos vivir en una realidad especial?
¿Y si viviéramos la realidad más elegante posible?
Imaginen la presión existencial sobre nosotros.
Para vivir a la altura, ser elegante,
y no desentonar.
¿Y si viviéramos en la más completa?
Nuestra existencia estaría garantizada,
porque cada cosa posible
existe en esa realidad,
nuestras decisiones no importarían.
Si luchara moralmente
y decidiera hacer lo correcto,
qué diferencia haría,
porque hay una cantidad infinita
de versiones de mí
que también hacen lo correcto
y una cantidad infinita que lo hacen mal.
Mis decisiones son insignificantes.
Así que no queremos vivir allí.
Y para la realidad especial de la nada,
no estaríamos teniendo esta conversación.
Creo que vivir en una realidad genérica es mediocre,
hay cosas buenas y malas,
y podríamos hacer más grandes las partes buenas
y más chicas las malas
y eso nos da un propósito.
En la vida, el universo es absurdo,
pero podemos construirnos un propósito,
y es uno muy bueno,
la mediocridad común de la realidad
resuena bien con
la mediocridad en el centro de nuestro ser.
Y Uds. lo sentirán.
Sé que todos son especiales,
pero son secretamente mediocres,
¿no lo creen?
(Risas) (Aplausos)
De todas formas, dirán, el rompecabezas de la existencia,
es solo un misterio tonto.
No están maravillados de la existencia del universo
y están en buena compañía.
Bertrand Russell dijo:
"Debería decir que el universo está ahí, y eso es todo".
Solo un dato duro.
Y mi profesor en Columbia, Sydney Morgenbesser,
un gran bromista filosófico,
cuando le dije: "Profesor Morgenbesser,
¿por qué hay algo en lugar de nada?
Me respondió: "Si no hubiera nada
tampoco estarías satisfecho".
Así que... (Risas) está bien.
Así que no están asombrados. No me importa.
Pero les diré algo para finalizar
que les garantizo los asombrará,
porque ha maravillado a todas las personas
brillantes que conocí en esta conferencia TED,
cuando les dije, y es esto:
Nunca en mi vida tuve un teléfono móvil.
Gracias.
(Risas) (Aplausos)